lunar valley a rugged mountainous region
on the border with pakistan what i saw
on that trip reinforced my
conviction that only the afghans have
the right and responsibility to leave
their country
and that more and endless american
military force
could not create or sustain a durable
afghan government
i believed that our presence in
afghanistan should be focused
on the reason we went in the first place
to ensure
afghanistan would not be used as a base
from which to attack our homeland again
we did that we accomplished that
objective
i said among with others we'd follow
osama bin laden to the gates of hell if
need be
that's exactly what we did and we got
him
it took us close to 10 years to put
president obama's
commitment to into form and that's
exactly what happened
osama bin laden was gone that was 10
years ago
think about that we delivered justice to
bin laden a decade ago
and we've stayed in afghanistan for a
decade since
since then our reasons for remaining in
afghanistan becoming increasingly
unclear
even as the terrorist threat that we
went to fight
evolved over the past 20 years the
threat has become more dispersed
metastasizing around the globe el shabab
in somalia
al-qaeda in the arabian peninsula
al-nusra in syria
isis attempting to create a kayla fight
in syria and iraq and establishing
affiliates in multiple countries
in africa and asia with the terror
threat now in many places
keeping thousands of troops grounded and
concentrated in just one country
at a cost of billions each year makes
little sense to me
and to our leaders we cannot continue
the cycle
of extending or expanding our military
presence in afghanistan
hoping to create ideal conditions for
the withdrawal
and expecting a different result i'm now
the fourth
united states president to preside over
american troop presence in afghanistan
two republicans
two democrats i will not pass
this responsibility onto a fifth
after consulting closely with our allies
and partners with our military leaders
and intelligence personnel with our
diplomats
and our development experts with the
congress and the vice president
as well as with mr ghani and many others
around the world
i've concluded that it's time to end
america's longest war
it's time for american troops to come
home
when i came to office i inherited a
diplomatic agreement
duly negotiated between the government
of the united states and the taliban
that all u.s forces would be out of
afghanistan by may 1 2021
just three months after my inauguration
that's what we inherited that commitment
it's perhaps not what i would have
negotiated myself
but it was an agreement made by the
united states government
and that means something so in keeping
with that agreement
with our national interest the united
states will begin
our final withdrawal begin it on may 1
of this year we'll not conduct a hasty
rush to the exit
we'll do it we'll do it responsibly
deliberately and safely
and we will do it in full coordination
with our allies and partners
who now have more forces in afghanistan
than we do
and the taliban should know that if they
attack us
as we draw down we will defend ourselves
and our partners with all
the tools at our disposal
our allies and partners have stood
beside us shoulder to shoulder in
afghanistan for almost
20 years and we're deeply grateful for
the contributions they have made
to our shared mission and for the
sacrifices they've borne
the plan has long been in together
out together u.s troops as well as
forces deployed by our nato allies
and operational partners will be out of
afghanistan before we mark
the 20th anniversary of that heinous
attack on september 11th
but but will not take our eye off the
terrorist threat
we'll reorganize our counterterrorism
capabilities
and the substantial assets in the region
to prevent reemergence of terrorists
from the threat to our homeland from
over the horizon
we'll hold the taliban accountable for
its commitment not to allow any
terrorists
to threaten the united states or its
allies from afghan soil
the afghan government has made that
commitment to us as well
and we'll focus our full attention on
the threat we face today
in my direction my team is refining our
national strategy
to monitor and disrupt significant
terrorist threats
not only in afghanistan but anywhere
they may arise
and they're in africa europe the middle
east and elsewhere
i spoke yesterday with president bush to
inform him of my decision
while he and i have had many
disagreements over police throughout the
years
we're absolutely united in our respect
and support
for the valor courage and integrity
of the women and men of the united
states armed forces who served
i'm immensely grateful for the bravery
and backbone
that they have shown through nearly two
decades of combat employments
we as a nation are forever indebted to
them and to their families
you all know that less than one percent
of americans serving armed forces
remaining 99 percent of we owe them
we owe them they've never backed down
from a single mission that we've asked
of them
i've witnessed their bravery first hand
during my visits to afghanistan
they've never wavered in the resolve
they've paid a tremendous price on our
behalf
and they have the thanks of a grateful
nation
will not stay involved in afghanistan
militarily
our diplomatic and humanitarian work
will continue
we'll continue to support the government
of afghanistan
we will keep providing assistance to the
afghan national defenses and security
forces
and along with our partners we have
trained and equipped
a standing force of over 300 000 afghan
personnel today
and hundreds of thousands over the past
two decades
and they'll continue to fight valiantly
on behalf of the afghans
at great cost they'll support peace
talks
as we will support peace talks between
the government afghanistan and the
taliban facilitated by the united
nations
and will continue to support the rights
of afghan women and girls
by maintaining significant humanitarian
and development assistance
and we'll ask other countries other
countries in the region to do more to
support afghanistan
especially pakistan as well as russia
china india and turkey they all have a
significant stake in the stable future
for afghanistan
and over the next few months we'll also
determine
what a continued u.s diplomatic presence
in afghanistan will look like including
how we'll ensure the security of our
diplomats
look i know there are many who will
loudly insist that diplomacy cannot
succeed without a robust
u.s military presence to stand as
leverage
we gave that argument a decade it's
never proved effective
not when we had 98 000 troops in
afghanistan
and not when we were down to a few
thousand
our diplomacy does not hinge on having
boots in harm's way
u.s boots on the ground we have to
change that thinking
american troops shouldn't be used as a
bargaining chip between warring parties
and other countries
you know that's nothing more than a
recipe for keeping american troops in
afghanistan indefinitely
i also know there are many who argue
that we should stay
stay fighting in afghanistan because
withdrawal would damage
america's credibility and weaken
america's influence in the world
i believe the exact opposite is true
we went to afghanistan because of a
horrific attack that happened
20 years ago that cannot explain why we
should remain there
in 2021 rather than
return to war with the taliban we have
to focus on the challenges that are in
front of us
we have to track and disrupt terrorist
networks and operations
that spread far beyond afghanistan since
9 11.
we have to show up american
competitiveness to meet the stiff
competition we're facing
from an increasingly assertive china we
have to strengthen our alliances and
work with like-minded partners
to ensure the rules of international
norms that govern
cyber threats and emerging technologies
that will shape our future
are grounded in our democratic values
values not those of the autocrats
we have to defeat this pandemic and
strengthen global health systems
to prepare for the next one because
there will be another pandemic
you know we'll be much more formidable
to our adversaries and competitors over
the long term
if we fight the battles for the next 20
years
not the last 20. and finally
the main argument for staying longer is
what each of my three predecessors have
grappled with
no one wants to say that we should be in
afghanistan forever
but they insist now is not the right
moment to leave
in 2014 nato issued a declaration
affirming that afghan security forces
would from that point on have full
responsibility for this country's
security
by the end of that year that was seven
years ago
so when will it be the right moment to
leave
one more year two more years 10 more
years
10 20 30 billion dollars more and
trillion we've already spent
not now that's how we got here
in this moment there's a significant
downside risk to saying beyond may 1st
without a clear timetable for departure
if we instead pursue the approach where
america
u.s exit is tied to conditions on the
ground
we have to have clear answers to the
following questions
just what conditions require to be
required to allow us
to depart by what means
and how long would it take to achieve
them if they could be achieved at all
and at what additional cost in lives and
treasure
i'm not heard any good answers to these
questions
and if you can't answer them in my view
we should
not stay the fact is that later today
i'm gonna visit arlington national
cemetery section 60
and that sacred memorial to american
sacrifice section assisted
section 60 is where our recent war dead
are buried
including many of the women and men who
died fighting in afghanistan and iraq
there's no there's no comforting
distance in history
in section 60. the grief is raw
it's a visceral reminder of the living
cost of war
for the past 12 years ever since i
became vice president
i've carried with me a card that reminds
me of the exact number of american
troops killed in iraq and afghanistan
that exact number not an approximation
or rounded off number because
every one of those dead
are sacred human beings who left behind
entire families
an exact accounting of every single
solitary one
needs to be had as of the day
today there are 240
2400 u.s troops and personnel
who've died in operation enduring
freedom and operation
freedoms sentinel or afghanistan
conflicts
twenty thousand 722 have been wounded
i'm the first president of 40 years who
knows what it means to have a child
serving in a war zone and throughout
this process my north star
has been remembering what it was like
when my late son beau was deployed to
iraq
how proud he was to service country how
insistent he was to deploy with his unit
and the impact it had on him and all of
us at home
we already have service members doing
their duty in afghanistan today
whose parents served in the same war
we have service members who are not yet
born
when our nation was attacked in 9 11.
war in afghanistan was never meant to be
a multi-generational undertaking
we were attacked we went to war with
clear goals
we achieved those objectives bin laden
is dead
and al qaeda is degraded in iraq and
afghanistan
and it's time to end the forever war
thank you all for listening may god
protect our troops may god bless all
those families
who lost someone in this endeavor
okay